this kid is not asking for [ __ ]  the reason this application is going  viral is there's a lot of people that  respect the [ __ ] out of this little  [ __ ] big shout out to this kid's  parents this kid wants an Xbox he's  trying to get a job and earn it the  reason this is going viral is because  obviously he's a did it but I'm telling  you the deeper thing is the respect  in a world where a lot of people just  got their hands out and are looking for  somebody to do it for him this little  man knows the score big shout out to  this kid  it hyped me I'm like happy  I hope this inspires someone to go get  it it's so much better when you get it  yourself  instead of asking someone for it  the best holidays everyone